bienvenue en ce des lois à l'occasion
des 1000 ans de la consécration de
l'abbaye saint philibert deux tours du
bon jean fabien devant jean pascal
bonjour à tous vous avez fait le bon
choix merci d'être avec nous sur france
3 nous allons ensemble déambuler pour
vous faire découvrir des choses
extraordinaires c'est donc en plusieurs
fabienne et oui pascal alors vous vous
allez déambuler à l'intérieur moi je
vais gravité par tout autour de l'abbaye
du monastère j'ai plein d'endroits vous
faire découvrir
je vous conseille de rester avec nous on
va les retrouver l'inp ajouts qui est
professeur de tourisme pour nous en dire
plus sur ce lieu exceptionnel
[Musique]
une fiction
tu
[Musique]
nous sommes très heureux de vous
accueillir ce vendredi matin et je suis
très heureux d'accueillir ligne pages où
cette fameuse professeur de tourisme
déjà ça donne envie un jour pascal et
bienvenue à tournus merci où sommes-nous
précisément les liens nous sommes dans
l'abbaye saint philibert et plus
précisément dans l'abbatiale et nous
sommes en train d'avancer nous étions
ici dans l'avant nef le narthex si vous
préférez et nous passons maintenant dans
la nef de l'obscurité à la lumière assez
loin quand plusieurs je suis sûr qu'on
va pouvoir découvrir à l'image que nous
pouvons voir ici il suffit de lever les
yeux au ciel pour se rendre compte que
cet espace est particulièrement magique
line et bien sûr il est magique c'est un
espace construit au tout début du 11e
siècle avec la particularité c'est que
vous êtes ici baignée dans la lumière
la lumière du jour et aussi la lumière
de dieu bien évidemment alors on voit
quelques vitraux on ira découvrir une
exposition 1 d'ici la fin de cette
émission avec l'ami fabienne qui
déambulent avec nous ce matin pour nous
faire découvrir aussi les coulisses
avant de revenir sur les vitraux avant
de s'intéresser un peu plus à tout ce
qui entoure la vie de tournée on a envie
de se dire il ya fontenay il y avait
gelé en bourgogne franche comté mais
qu'est ce qui fait la différence ici à
tournus non mais vous pouvez pas dire ça
à pascal parce que si je vous parle de
fontenay si vous me parlez de vézelay je
vous me parlez du 12e siècle
moi je vous parle de l'origine l'art
roman il est presque né à tournus il est
presque né à tournus pourquoi parce
qu'ici vous êtes dans une église de
maçon et cette église de maçon c'est ce
que vous voyez là est ce que les
téléspectateurs sont en train de voir
et bien c'est les origines de cet art
roman qui va se développer sur des
grands sites comme vous laisse vous
venez d'évoquer cluny vézelay et
fontenay en tout cas c'est un des
ensembles religieux les plus vieux de
france qui atteindra poursuivre la
visite 1 d'ici quelques instants
mais comme promis on va les retrouver
fabienne et toute l'équipe il se trouve
en fait en dessous
fabienne et sous la crypte et vous allez
voir c'est assez magique et
et ce n'est que le début vous avez fait
le bon choix c'est france 3 ensemble
c'est mieux pascal vous avez bien fait
de me laisser m'échapper un petit peu et
profiter tout seul de la visite parce
que j'ai quelque chose d'incroyable à
vous montrer du coup je suis tombé sur
cette crypte à l'instant cette crypte
historique où nous attend lauriane qui
est animatrice du patrimoine
bonjour là bonjour est-ce que vous
pouvez nous expliquer où on se trouve
ici précisément on se trouve au coeur de
la crypte souterraine qui se trouve
juste en dessous de l'église principale
il ya une histoire et si un jour la
chine ya même des histoires un petit peu
merveilleuse dites nous tout si on
s'approche un petit peu de ce puits
l'eau serait miraculeuse
tout simplement parce qu'on aurait jeté
la tête de saint valérien et l'eau
serait aurait des vertus curatives
contre les maladies il ya encore de
l'eau dans le puits donc de temps en
temps il peut y en avoir pas aujourd'hui
alors vous nous parlez de saint-valérien
mais nous depuis tout à l'heure on
évoque sans philibert alors qu'elle est
le distinguo affaire la saint philibert
sept enfants dont les reliques sont
arrivés plus tardivement et c'est saint
valérien qui est le saint local qui a
été martyrisé au deuxième siècle à
tournus il ya une histoire avec saint
valérien non exactement parce qu'il
aurait été martyrisé et enterrés ici on
serait sur son lieu de sépulture
là on se trouve là on restera exactement
alors cet endroit existait avant
l'église au dessus de nous alors
effectivement parce qu'elle sert
d'assise à l'église sans la crypte pas
d'église au dessus et c'est l'endroit
qui a qui aide qui est très beau qui est
très mystérieux c'est surtout aussi d'un
point de vue architectural s'émeuvent
c'est assez beau on a ces colonnes qui
sont là et on a aussi tout la méthode de
construction des maîtres maçons de
l'époque au moyen-âge parce qu'on voit
même sa part est un peu frustré comme ça
quand on regarde mais c'est vraiment le
système de réalisation le système de
construction du début du de l'an mil
alors en plus qu'il faut dire le rien de
c'est que nous on a beaucoup de chance
aujourd'hui grâce à nos équipes
techniques fait vrai c'est très lumineux
très éclairé c'est très rare s'est
beaucoup plus sombre
même si on est un petit peu de lumière
généralement c'est beaucoup plus sombre
même si on a un petit peu de lumière qui
vient de l'extérieur parce que c'est une
crypte qui est semi enterrés donc on a
un tout petit peu de lumière mais
d'habitude c'est beaucoup plus sans que
sa victime
donc aujourd'hui on peut apprécier le
fait que ces colonnes est vraiment un
travail assez remarquable y en a pas une
identique à un haut niveau des
chapiteaux tous les chapiteaux sont
différents et ce qui est assez étonnant
c'est que ces colonnes font penser un
petit peu à l'église au dessus c'est
comme si on avait une mini église
souterraine
c'est l'idée en ces lignes et l'unac rim
soit une mini église j'ai vraiment ça
une mini église qui permet les
processions des pèlerins pour aller se
recueillir sur les reliques
à l'époque il faut donc imaginer qu'il y
avait des pèlerins et des reliques ici
aujourd'hui les touristes viennent quand
même un j'imagine découvrir cet espace
te viennent quand même
les enfants adorent la crypte évidemment
parce que parfois c'est très sympathique
un petit peu a joué à cache cache et il
peut parfois y avoir des cérémonies
c'est un petit peu plus rare d'amer au
moyen-age on avait vraiment des
processions d'accord alors on va
continuer d'avancer un petit peu un
lauriane parce que vous m'avez indiqué
qu' au niveau du plafond là vous aviez
quelque chose à nous montrer que chaque
nourrissent bien apprécié alors
généralement les touristes ne vois pas
s'il faut vraiment qu'on leur explique
mais quand on regarde un petit peu plus
précisément la voûte on se rend compte
qu'il ya des petits bouts de bois qui
sont restés accrochés dans le coffrage
c'est le bout de bois qui servait du le
coffrage au moment de la construction de
l'église donc vraiment c'est du bois b10
dubois médiévale on imagine les mâts
sont en train de poser le tévelave et de
l'enlever et oui et alors il faut qu'on
termine quand même brièvement sur cet
espace ce sarcophage
lauriane qui est dédié donc à face en
valais rien exactement notre martyr
locale notre saint local
si on s'approche un peu on retrouvera
plus de reliques à l'intérieur cela va
prendre le temps de s'approcher aussi
évident il évident aujourd'hui pendant
les guerres de religion le corps a
certainement été détruits mais on a
encore le sarcophage ici de ce fameux
saint valérien
donc il ya deux histoires ici qui se
rejoignent finalement la légende avec la
grèce dans le bruit et le corps de saint
valérien
merci mes organes force des explications
je vous rejoins à l'extérieur de
l'église parce qu'elle passe que vous
allez voir qu'il ya quand même plein
d'autres choses à dire forcément merci
fabienne toujours avec vous depuis
tournus en plein coeur de l'abbatiale
ici avec on peut lire un décor
exceptionnel et des voûtes qu'on voit
l'image actuellement qui sont assez
particulières c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire oui assez particulière alors
je vais utiliser juste un petit élément
qui du tout une feuille qui va vous
permettre de comprendre le système du
vêtement de l'art roman et la
particularité tournus
quand vous voyez une feuille vous voyez
ici que je suis obligé de la positionner
de cette manière là et vous voyez qui si
vous avez des pressions sur les côtés et
ce sont mes mains qui sont là pour faire
ces pressions ce qui veut dire que quand
vous regardez l'édifice vous avez lac ce
qui est là et dans un édifice roman la
particularité c'est que vous n'avez pas
de lumière pourquoi parce que vous êtes
obligés de concevoir de pousser sur les
côtés la particularité de tournus c'est
quand on regarde là haut on se rend bien
compte qu'on a de la lumière mais on n'a
pas une seule goutte
en fait le système est le même
simplement on a juste fait un quart de
tour et à partir de ce moment là on peut
avoir comme vous pouvez le voir de part
et d'autre et bien de la lumière et la
particularité tournus c'est qu'on a
testé quelque chose on s'est dit on veut
faire au on veut faire grand et on veut
faire lumineux on utilise ce système on
le multiplie sur une dizaine de voûte et
ça permet exceptionnellement et bien
avoir un édifice très haut et très
lumineux c'est grand c'est long oui
c'est impressionnant tout à fait c'est
d'eau aussi avec ses fameux vitraux va
découvrir quelques images parce que
c'est vrai que ici on se rend compte du
travail qui est assez exceptionnel tout
à fait les vitraux ici date du 2 alors
date je devrais être beaucoup plus
précise et dire que c'est après la
deuxième guerre mondiale qu'on a fait le
choix quand on a refait l'église est
bien de faire des vitraux contemporains
ou le choix et la lumière
donc je crois que votre reportage nous
permettra de le montrer oui oui d'ici la
fin de cette émission avec fabienne on
va les découvrir
celui qui est à l'origine de tout ça en
tout cas celui qui à retravailler tout
ces vitraux et ça sera assez surprenant
c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire
puisqu'on est dans les choses
surprenantes pourrait tout aussi bien
parler des mosaïques à beewi les
mosaïques que vous trouvez là bas eh
bien ces mosaïques la particularité de
ces mosaïques c'est qu'elles sont des
influences antique
alors vous allez me dire l'antiquité on
est très très loin quand on est ici au
12e siècle
simplement on est sur un passage un
passage vous connaissez l'autoroute a6
eh bien vous savez sûrement aussi et
bien que c'était une ancienne voie
romaine et c'est sur cette voie romaine
et bien que tout tout la toule les
technicités ont traversé le temps
pendant plus de mille ans et au xième
siècle vous avez ici une église qui est
très très puissante et qui a les moyens
de faire des choses et quand on ira voir
là bas vous verrez qu'on ait
véritablement donc dans une technicité
très importante et on a un calendrier
qui nous raconte très bien qui nous
racontent les saisons et les trois
éléments qu'on vous mettra en valeur son
le mois de mai le mois de juin et le
mois de juillet on commence en tout cas
à mieux comprendre line pajot pourquoi
finalement tournus a envie que l'on
classe cet endroit au patrimoine mondial
de l'unesco
c'est évident vous comprenez maintenant
on va encore mieux comprendre maintenant
avec quelques images et un petit retour
en arrière pour en comprendre cette
candidature regarder le maire et
l'historien n'ont pas fini d'échanger
sur le sujet comment parvenir à monter
un dossier solide qui finirait par
séduire l'unesco pour aboutir à ce
résultat
aujourd'hui tout le monde connaît la
bête tournus comme une belle église
romane
il faudrait que demain tout le monde
commet connaissent tournus comme un site
remarquable historique unique au monde
du strict point de vue de son
architecture et de son histoire
l'ensemble abbatial de tournus est
effectivement remarquable des monuments
du même type s'était faire des abbayes
cisterciennes il y en a beaucoup qui
sont encore debout qui on était
inscrite au patrimoine fontenay vsd
mais aussi ancienne que celle ci il n'y
en a pas cette réalité personne ne la
conteste
mais cela suffira-t-il pour intégrer le
patrimoine mondial au delà des données
objectives il y a les tendances de
l'unesco si tournus avait fait sa
demande voici trente ou quarante ans
elle aurait sans doute eu gain de cause
mais aujourd'hui il y a déjà beaucoup
d'édifices de la période romane qui sont
classés et c'est plutôt le patrimoine
immatériel savoir-faire ou tradition qui
a le vent en poupe
autant dire que la sphère n'est pas dans
le sac à moins peut-être d'élargir le
dossier à la situation particulière de
tournai tournure en en quelques mots
c'est aussi d'une certaine façon une
frontière une limite c'est la plus au
nord
des influences du sud est peut-être la
plus au sud des influences du nord
passer d'une belle église romane à un
site remarquable classé au patrimoine
mondial de l'unesco
line pajot c'est un défi qui n'est pas
forcément évident à relever messieurs
vous avez messi mais on le veut on le
veut
vous l'avez vu on est dans un édifice
exceptionnel qui fait ses mille ans les
mini lord sa consécration
oui c'est un préciser parce que il y en
a qui vont me dire mais attendez vous
chipotez c'est pas me lancer les 1800
voilà si on veut être précis c'est bien
plus vieux que ça alors c'est tellement
évident qu'on soit classée au patrimoine
mondial de l'unesco qu'aucun tournusien
vous dira que c'est pas possible donc
toute la population tournusienne est
derrière ce projet pour classer cet
édifice est bien au patrimoine
alors là on va se donner rendez vous
d'ici quelques mois la deadline en
attend la réponse pour quand alors il
faut être honnête patrimoine mondial de
l'unesco c'est sûr c'est un projet qui
est à très très long terme tellement
long terme que d'ici je pense entre 5 et
10 ans donc on est vraiment sur quelque
chose à très long terme mais la
consécration mais millénaire et et cette
année c
premier pas pour que non plus les
tournusiens mais les bourguignons et les
gens de la franche-comté puisse
connaître et reconnaître ce patrimoine
au niveau régional une certitude on va
pouvoir le vérifier dans quelques
minutes avec monsieur le maire qui va
nous rejoindre et le prêtre de cet habit
ici on fait tout un vraiment pour que
tournus passe devant encore une fois
parce que vous avez quand même la chance
d'avoir un édifice qui est en pleine
forme si j'ose dire
tout à fait contrairement à cluny on va
balancer un petit peu ou à d'autres
allons-y on va être un peu chauvin
franchement c'est différent ici abbas
est différent tout simplement parce que
c'est entier donc ce qu'est ce qui est
important c'est que à cluny
oui c'était la plus grande église de la
chrétienté mais aujourd'hui quand vous
allez à cluny
que reste-t-il alors qu'ici vous avez
véritablement un édifice du 11e siècle à
la fois l'église mais aussi tous les
bâtiments monastiques qui sont encore
entier une page vous allez rester avec
nous un parce que je veux absolument
qu'on se retrouve d'ici la fin de cette
émission parce que moi je vous écouterai
pendant encore 40 minutes le problème
c'est que on a notamment fabien da costa
qui est avec nous et qui déambulent tout
ce vendredi matin
et aujourd'hui elle a décidé de
poursuivre sa petite aventure en
rencontrer quelqu'un que vous connaissez
bien puisque on va les découvrir ce qui
se passe à l'extérieur cette fois ci du
côté du parc pas très très loin de
l'abbaye ici pour parler tourisme autour
de ses mille ans de l'abbatiale de
tournus d'où nous sommes avec vous ce
matin parce que vous savez en somme
c'est vraiment mieux
pascal je continue pour ma part vous
l'avez dit de gravité un petit peu
autour de vous autour de l'abbaye
je suis cette fois dans un parc à deux
pas de vous avec ma nouvelle invitée
priscilla du bruit qui est responsable
de l'office de tourisme à priscilla
cette consécration ce millénaire il faut
le dire c'est quand même une belle
opportunité pour tournus là oui tout à
fait et oui le programme on a un
programme d'animations très très riche
très très varié il y en a pour tous les
goûts ya des conférences des concerts
des expositions notamment une très très
belle exposition en fait l'exposition
quoi de neuf au moyen-âge qui débutera
du le 15 juin pour se terminer le 22
septembre
et puis de gros concerts barbara
hendricks
x galliano marc barr hendrickson de foot
galliano le 28 juillet enfin beaucoup
beaucoup d'animations beaucoup de choses
c'est une année à ne pas manquer à
tournus l'idée c'est de faire venir
d'autres touristes un autre type de
public que celui qui vient ici en temps
normal visiter l'abbaye ou pas
spécialement bah écoutez si
effectivement puisqu'on a eu l'occasion
de pouvoir faire des salons de promotion
touristique avec le programme de
manifestations du millénaire
et ça marche vraiment les gens sont en
fait cette célébration la consécration
tous ces événements c'est l'occasion de
venir ici de découvrir tournus pourquoi
pas faire tourner en 2019 puisqu'il ya
ce beau programme d'animations donc
c'est vrai que j'ai testé et je peux
dire que c'est vraiment voilà il ya un
effet whaou ah oui on ira le week end
dernier notamment on était à evian et
c'est vrai que les gens étaient très
intéressés beaucoup de gens du mondial
mais on va venir csu par l'adema la
nation tout à fait tout à fait tournus
c'est une petite ville 1 6000 habitants
à la ccin une petite vie mais avions
déjà quand même pas mal de touristes non
oui effectivement tournus est une ville
très touristique de par l'abbaye saint
philibert mais pas que nous voyons aussi
la chance d'avoir un très très beau
musée l'hôtel-dieu musée greuze donc un
peu comme les hospices de beaune
voiliers et puis aussi un musée du vélo
dans les environs immédiats on a un
superbe site qui est le site de brancion
et puis on a la chance d'avoir la saône
d'avoir des bus pas mal de possibilités
de randonnées de balades à vélo on à la
sortie d'autoroute qui fait que les gens
viennent facilement ici font une étape
et puis se disent mais ces superbes on
reviendra oui on entend tout l'été à
l'accueil est vraiment fait vous pouvez
toucher plusieurs publics les
bourguignons ce durant effectivement les
bourguignons les locaux en fait tous les
gens bas du département et des mêmes des
départements limitrophes viennent sont
des ambassadeurs de tournus très souvent
quand ils ont de la famille qui arrive
d'ailleurs de l'étranger viennent à
tournus leur font découvrir notre ville
on a vraiment tout à fait ce genre de
tout faire un look différent il ya ce
monastère cette abbaye qui fait la
notoriété de tournus est ce que les gens
sont au courant qu'il ya d'autres choses
il ya la gastronomie peut-être la lettre
de huy tournus est effectivement très
connu par la gastronomie et puis on est
aussi la porte d'entrée nord du vignoble
du mâconnais
ce qui fait aussi un atout
supplémentaire pour la vie
donc les gens bahia il ya des gens qui
viennent pour la gastronomie d'autres
qui viennent pour le patrimoine de
patrimoine roman pardon puisque tournus
et quand même un cas d'école et elle est
pour tous les élèves qui fraye des
études d'architecturé incontournable
c'est incontournable effectivement on
vient plutôt pour une halte sur une
journée un week end
est ce qu'il ya une logique là à
conseiller pour venir profiter de ce
millénaire
tout dépend de vos on vient ainsi miné
tout à côté par exemple pour les gens
qui viennent de la région bourgogne
franche comté c'est facile de lui faire
sur une journée et puis après
effectivement si vous venez de plus loin
deux jours c'est intéressant mais on a
on a tous types de visiteurs on a même
des gens qui passent plusieurs semaines
l'été ça arrive ici ils ont des maisons
des résines aux vacances faire parce
qu'ils sont tombés sous le charme en
fait de notre territoire donc c'est vrai
qu'on y est enfin avec la sortie
d'autoroute la gare c'est vraiment
facile de venir ici on sait c'est très
pratique un petite commune mais très
accueillante vous savez en tout cas bien
faire la promotion de cette destination
avec une exposition notamment c'est ce
dont je vais vous parlé tout à l'heure
pascal une exposition de vitraux juste à
côté
fait on est toujours ici en
saône-et-loire à tournus à l'occasion
des 1000 ans de la consécration de
cet habit particulière et je suis ravi
d'accueillir avec nous ce matin monsieur
le maire merci d'être avec nous bertrand
vos bonjour pascal merci de nous
accueillir à tournus on va découvrir que
tournus c'est dynamique ça se vitalise
contrairement à quelques idées reçues
mais d'abord si vous me le permettez
on est quand même ici les modestes
invités du locataire que vous êtes vous
en permanence dominique oudot vous êtes
le prêtre de cette paroisse qui nous
accueille ce matin
bonjour pascal merci d'être avec nous et
c'est un grand bonheur on voit à l'image
quelques magnifiques endroits
moi j'ai repéré par exemple cet orgue
lacan est en train de voir parlez-moi de
cet instrument qui est quand même assez
majestueux complètement
il a un très beau buffet il est en
parfait état et on a la chance d'avoir
trois organismes qui est tous les
dimanches nous aident à prier en musique
et puis d'avoir plusieurs fois par an
des beaux concerts d'orgue dont un
festival qui s'appelle ordre en
ascension où chaque année quatre jeunes
organistes viennent montrer leurs
talents souvent venus de france mais
aussi de suisse ou d'allemagne
et puis à nos organismes qui clôture
avec un concert majestueux alors c'est
vrai qu'alain festival d'orgue mais
aussi beaucoup de choses qu'on peut voir
ici à tournus et il suffit simplement de
sortir pour se rendre compte que tournus
est en train de changer c'est le moins
qu'on puisse dire bertrand vos bas je
vous remercie décès constatés on fait
tout pour ça je peux être très honnête
jusqu'au bout et dire que en préparant
cette émission je suis allé me balader
dans les petites ruelles de tournus et
franchement ça donne envie
si j'osais je dirais à ceux qui n'en
sont pas convaincus
arrêtez-vous parce qu'on parlait de
cluny tout à l'heure on parlait de
fontenay en parler d'autres endroits et
malheureusement vous êtes un tout petit
peu moins connus ccc mauvais côté des
choses bertrand alors c'est vrai que
tournus à moins de notoriété que les
endroits que vous venez de décrire
cependant on a de nombreux visiteurs
plus que les endroits clés que vous
venez de décrire un ailier à peu près
déjà deux cent mille visiteurs par an à
tournus et c'est un atout pour nous déjà
mais je pense qu'il pourrait y en avoir
plus effectivement donc il faut pas
hésiter à dire que tournus est une ville
un peu mystère un peu cachée mais c'est
ce qui participe à son charme
d'autant que cet anniversaire
prestigieux
c'est milan donne lieu à de nombreuses
manifestations qui vont avoir lieu toute
cette année 2019
oui qui ont déjà commencé et qu'ils vont
avoir lieu tout l'été avec un point
d'orgue c'est la journée millénium du 15
juin et le 9 août barbara hendricks qui
nous fait le bonheur et la joie de venir
chanter dans cette merveilleuse abbaye
il est très clair que valoriser la ville
son patrimoine c'est forcément un plus
important du pour savoir où on va il
faut savoir d'où on vient et donc
l'histoire d'une ville histoire de ses
habitants la connaître ça apporte de la
cohérence pour construire le projet
d'avenir pour la ville alors vous faites
beaucoup d'efforts 1 pour transformer
tournus on va le voir vous faites venir
et revenir le plus de monde possible
c'est votre défi quotidien on va le
comprendre l'image puis nous reviendrons
ici ensemble à tournus regarder lorsque
le maire nous fait la visite de tournus
il ne manque pas de projets alors le but
ici ce serait de faire des terrasses de
café de revoir complètement la
disposition générale de revoir la place
de la voiture pour y faire vraiment un
lieu sympathique attractif réaménagement
de deux places d'un quartier de logement
ou encore modernisation de la
bibliothèque
les idées sont là et 2 millions d'euros
sous sur la table pour revitaliser le
bourg pourtant il y en a encore deux ans
ce n'était pas gagné
un projet de centre commercial en
périphérie de la ville avait provoqué un
tollé
jusqu'au départ de l'ancien maire les
habitants s'étaient mobilisés pour
sauver le centre ville aujourd'hui pour
le nouveau maire c'est de l'histoire
ancienne
tiens famille cement hier j'ai eu cinq
demandes de permis de construire sa part
irait depuis des années quand on regarde
tournus depuis un an à peu près on voit
des grues partout on n'a jamais eu
autant de personnes privées qui ont
refait leur toiture qui sont en train de
refaire leur façade
donc on voit que la ville commence à se
transformer et ça c'est très
enthousiasmant
premier bénéficiaire de cet élan le
cinéma de la ville entièrement remise à
neuf pour la ville impensable de le
laisser tomber en désuétude il ya qu un
cinéma à 30 kilomètres à la ronde et
6000 habitants à tournus mais on touche
la communauté de communes voire des
villages un peu plus loin pour ne pas
dire même mâcon chalon sur notre
programmation plus pointue
du coup ça oblige les gens à venir en
voiture à venir à tournus faire venir
faire revenir les gens à tournus un
objectif qui a de quoi séduire tout le
monde et c'est mathématique
ce commerçant y trouve son compte car en
plus de gens qui viendront dans le
centre donc potentiellement klich de
clients et aussi en termes
d'attractivité touristique
parce que si on réhabilite logement si
on réhabilite les ruelles
si on met en avant les avantages que
représente la saône les vieux quartiers
on aura plus de gens qui viendront
peut-être se promener peut-être faire
des achats
la ville attire de nouveaux
investisseurs cet entrepreneur s'est
lancé dans la construction d'un hôtel
grand luxe
pour lui il n'ya qu'un avenir possible à
tournus ce qui peut sauver tournus c'est
le touriste alors c'est bien par là
l'accueil de l'hôtellerie par l'abbaye
qui est présent par les musées par
l'environnement qu'on peut créer autour
de tournus et l'année mais au quotidien
à l'heure où les centres villes sont
plutôt victimes de fermeture de
commerces
le plan de revitalisation du bourg signé
avec la région est une petite bouffée
d'oxygène
toujours avec vous ici depuis tournus
parce que le bars en bleu c'est mieux du
lundi au vendredi à partir de 10h50
avant votre 12 13 en compagnie de
bertrand vos on vient de vous voir dans
ce sujet on l'a compris la ville de
tournus se transforme bertrand oui il se
transforme elle a besoin il faut vivre
avec son temps il faut se moderniser et
puis surtout les petites villes comme
nous souffrons d'une dévitalisation
depuis milieu des années 70 5 omap
toutes les petites et moyennes villes de
france on est pris dans l'étau du rêve
pavillonnaire d'un côté et du dynamisme
des grandes métropoles de l'autre et il
faut absolument inverser cette tendance
donc c'est ce que nous essayons de faire
en ce moment
est ce qu'on essaie de faire ici aussi
dans cette paroisse à tournus avec vous
dominique oudot parce que votre
quotidien c'est vraiment de faire vivre
cet endroit alors bien sûr que
l'abbatiale et le site abbatial
c'est d'abord un lieu vénérable et qui
nous rappelle un passé des pages
prestigieuse du passé et humain et
spirituel ici mais c'est aussi une
église paroissiale et c'est un petit peu
le challenge permanent à la fois de
faire vivre une paroisse dans ce lieu et
puis aussi d'accueillir des gros des
familles qui viennent pour admirer des
belles pierres et qui sont sensibles
d'ailleurs aussi à ce qui se dit ici
dans la ville comme l'a dit monsieur le
maire mais aussi dans la paroisse qui
est très active
quelques petites pépites on va dire
notamment dans l'accueil
l'accompagnement de déboutés du droit
d'asile comme nous y encouragent le père
françois
et puis avec une vie liturgique assez
dense l'église n'est jamais vide ici les
dimanches on l'a toujours des belle
assemblée
justement dominique oudot il ya quelques
minutes à peine il y avait encore des
groupes là qui déambulait alors voilà la
magie de la télévision fait qu ils ont
disparu mais ils peuvent surgir à tout
moment d'ici la fin de cette émission
qu'est ce que vous demande ces groupes
quand il visite ici à tourner alors
assez souvent ils viennent avec leur
propre guide ils frappent aussi à la
porte de l'office de tourisme qui les
renseignent qui est parfois les guides
aussi et puis dans la paroisse il ya un
certain nombre de personnes qui
volontiers aussi à la demande font
visiter en assistant peut-être moins sur
l'aspect architectural sur lequel il ya
tant à dire que sur l'aspect spirituel
et sur une vie des chrétiens à tournus
qui est magnifique puisque ici il ya des
chrétiens depuis 179
le martyre d'un certain valérien il ya
eu toutes les époques des moines qui ont
amené ici depuis noirmoutier les
reliques de saint philibert on en a
parlé avec fabien vient seulement 1
quelques minutes elle était sous la
crypte à l'italie aussi du côté
de l'extérieur pour nous faire vivre
tout ce qui se passait avec les
animations pour les 1000 ans les mille
ans et pas n'importe quoi il y aura un
gâteau dit moi dominique oudot
suffisamment de bougies peut-être
beaucoup de gâteaux et moi je suis très
sensible et le maire de la ville dès le
début de la préparation a toujours dit
on regarde le passé mais dont il ya un
millénaire passé et toute cette belle
histoire humaine et spirituelle et
chrétiens de vaut le coup d'être fêté
mais c'est surtout pour aller avancer
vers l'avenir
non on va avancer nous aussi vers
l'avenir j'ai envie de vous remercier
tous les deux si je vous dis réfectoire
des moines
dominique forcément ça vous dit quelque
chose oui et puis quand même c'est à
signaler que ce site abbatial est un
site unique en europe où tout est encore
présent et elle réfectoire médias le
scellier il ya l'abbatiale il ya le
cloître et à la salle capitulaire et
j'en oublie sûrement
tout est resté attaque on va laisser à
stéphane bern un jour peut-être
l'occasion de venir pour france
télévisions vous faire une grande grande
grande émission on espère nous vous
savez on en fait une par jour donc c'est
déjà beaucoup
on va s'arrêter quand même quelques
instants réflecteurs des moines pour
justement aller y ait retrouvé fabienne
qui a rencontré le maître verrier de ces
fameux vitro que vous avez pu découvrir
tout à l'heure à l'image pascal nous
voici cette fois dans une dernière pièce
que je voudrais vous vous montrez le
réfectoire là où les moines venez manger
tout simplement
c'est plus du tout un réfectoire
aujourd'hui c'est un lieu d'exposition
où l'on vous retrouve pierre alain
parrot bonjour vous êtes vitrailliste
alors c'est l'occasion de découvrir une
sorte d'exposition plutôt insolite un
des vitraux d'habitude ça s'expose pas
les vôtres en revanche sont exposés ici
pour ce pour ce millénaire oui ce sont
des des fragments des démons des
morceaux ont fait de vitraux qui sont
installés dans des cathédrales pour des
gros grand chantier de création et là on
expose des panneaux décès des panneaux
ont été réalisés en double qui permet
justement de la cité à la visite dans
les rues rendant les lieux sur lesquels
ils sont exposés plus tôt des croquis ou
tout ce que vous faisiez avant les
vraies vies trop posé sur les
cathédrales des panneaux décès des
panneaux témoins des panneaux qui
permettent aussi aux commanditaires
l'état par exemple sur place de juger du
travail
il sera réalisé donc c'est des restes ne
sait pas dire est d'atelier mais presque
voilà mais quand ils sont combien
spectaculaire il donne l'impression de
ce que va dire oui l'église dans les
visages ils sont déjà bien assez haut
pour qu'on se rende compte de l'échelle
réelle dans les églises effectivement
votre travail de vitrailliste il a
plusieurs volets il ya de la
restauration il ya de la création les
principales travail principale
occupation des ateliers c'est la
conservation-restauration mille ans
d'histoire du vitrail à restaurer et à
entretenir
et puis le donc ça c'est une activité
vraiment importante c'est que deux
spécialistes maintenant scientifique et
puis on a deuxième volet qui est la
création contemporaine d'arts
contemporains comme un maître verrier au
xvième siècle un restaurer le siècle
précédent et entretenaient entretenait
des siècles précédents et et crée le
patrimoine du 16e siècle donc le
aujourd'hui en création c'est aussi bien
mes propres créations ce cas là c'est
difficile parce que de plus en plus au
moment de faire équipe avec des artistes
plasticiens et donc c'est l'exemple de
deux skoda soir doit la country beaux
atours ici c'est mathieu tyson en
anglais à la cathédrale saint claude
dans le jura
c'était une recherche sur le vert blanc
et sur le ver rouge des fabrications
spéciales c'est toujours cette recherche
de technicité pour répondre à la 2e au
dialogue que l'on entretient avec
l'artiste
ça c'est un travail qui vous demandent
énormément d'années on se rend pas
compte nous un faire un vitrail c'est
long oui oui bah ça dépend la complexité
pour tous ces phases de recherche de
mise au point des techniques de dialogue
avec l'artiste n'est pas de réalisation
de panneaux témoins et puis de de mise
en place après dans les ateliers ça peut
durer plusieurs mois voire un an ou deux
terrell de tours c'était céder
pratiquement deux ans de travail est-ce
que vous avez besoin d'avoir une
connaissance précise de l'histoire
religieuse de la bible aussi pour faire
ça bien sûr oui parce qu'il ya comme une
vocation
spirituel du vitrail nella sens de la
lumière l'abbé suger xiième siècle
disait fait des vitraux les plus radieux
pour qu'ils explorent qu'ils traduisent
la lumière de dieu c'est important quand
la lumière c'est quand même un élément
sensible un élément spirituel donc
effectivement il a travaillé sur la
lumière chaque vitrail à son sa petite
singularité on le voit encore avec celui
ci donc qui vient de la cathédrale
l'église de talent les dames avec gérard
garouste est un autre projet important
qui a eu lieu il ya déjà une vingtaine
d'années mais qu'on l'a remis là parce
que vraiment c'est toujours un moment
très important dans l'histoire du
vitrail gérard garouste avait souhaité
que l'on ferait fabrique des verts ans
yves colmou xiième siècle on a monté une
vérité nos ateliers pour fabriquer un
verre fabriqué comme au 12e siècle
et puis tout ce travail sur la peinture
sur verre l' attaque à l'acide et
gravures ainsi de suite car donner une
heure extraordinaire il ya beaucoup de
monde qui vient visiter la découvrir vos
beaux vitraux dans le cadre de ce
millénaire c'est l'occasion de faire
connaître votre métier aussi un sujet
occasion de montrer ce volet le
conservation et puis aussi restauration
que le vitrail sip accueil du passéisme
c'est aussi un art contemporain vivant
et qui permet justement à des artistes
de s'exprimer à travers le verre et le
vitrail est ce que vous êtes allé
pierre-alain découvrir les vitraux de
l'abbaye juste à côté de nous ici à
tournus oui oui ces défis trop content
effet dans les années 50 par brigitte
simon cd vitrerie ces belles très clair
ce très sobre très féminine des roses
des bleu et blanc ce très beau but c'est
le début du vitrail contemporain ce
qu'on a pu découvrir avec elle la dans
l'abbaye et par après guerre il ya eu
une grande une grande 2
mutations sur le vitrail contemporain
avec les ateliers d'art sacré la franche
comté a été propre a été vraiment leader
dans la dans la création contemporaine
ronchamp avec le groupe huissier
manessier aux bréseux ça a été un des
grands centres de création contemporaine
la franche comté et puis il ya ce type
de vitraux qui sont encore les vautrin
pierre-alain des vitraux pour lesquelles
vous aviez eu un prix à la cathédrale de
strasbourg il ya deux ans ça représente
et dites-nous rapidement énormément de
travail plusieurs années il ya un an et
demi de travail là sur ce vitrail avec
une artiste photographe qui nous a livré
une oeuvre photographique et l'a fallu
la traduire en verre et en verre en
apprend faisant des impressions
numériques de nos produits du vitrail
sur la clé le vert les recuire et puis
rajouter une double peau en vitrail pour
redonner cet éclat des rouges et des
bleus dans l'est sur le thème de
sainte-catherine s'inviterait sur le
thème de sainte catherine
nous avions pu nous il y a deux ans à
l'époque découvrir un petit peu l'envers
du décor comment vous avez pu préparer
ses vitraux dans votre atelier des
horaires en côte d'or je vous propose de
découvrir le reportage fait il y a deux
ans et je vous rejoins moi tout à
l'heure dans dans le cloître pascal
deux ans de travail récompensé avec une
création originale
révélé l'an dernier à la cathédrale de
strasbourg
un vitrail où son visage derrière cette
oeuvre d'art pierre alain parent c'est
dans son atelier que le vitrail a pris
forme
mois après mois un projet inédit réalisé
avec une plasticienne photographe
intéressant c'était d'essayer de
remporter ce challenge de reproduire sur
verre des photographies avec nos
techniques pérennes du vitrail c'est à
dire des émaux qui sont des couleurs
vitry fiable qui sont intégrées dans le
vert à haute température et qui donne à
décor complètement indélébile et qui
franchira les siècles oeuvres mouvantes
le vitrail est indissociable de la
lumière qui le traversent
alors pour créer il faut une large
palette de couleurs aux nuances révélée
par le soleil car travailler le verre
c'est avant tout travailler avec la
lumière en vitrail sont les miens ne vit
pas et les noirs on voit très bien donc
révélateur de la couleur dans le vert
c'est le sait le soleil et la lumière
naturelle qui grâce aux oxydes
métalliques qui sont dans le vert ont
filtré cette lumière naturelle il
laissait passer therion rouge bleu ou
jaune vert en plus des créations
pierre-alain part au restaurent c'est
d'ailleurs son activité principale
un travail long et minutieux comme sur
ce vitrail de la cathédrale de bayonne
du 15e siècle une pièce creusé par l'eau
principal élu du verre l'idée c'est
vraiment de supprimer les produits
l'altération qui risque de maintenir
inité surface des verts et de modifier
le problème de péage qui sont la surface
des verts en plus ces vitraux seront
protégés par une double verrière donc
ils seront plus soumis à l'agression
physique et celle it du temps pour aider
le maître verrier une douzaine de
petites mains chargées de recomposer ces
pièces de puzzle très particulière c'est
la remise en plomb elle consiste à
remplacer les anciens plomb avant de les
souder toutes les étapes en vitrail
prennent du temps
c'est quand même des oeuvres d'art
fragile sept vitraux ont été créés en
dix ans qu'un 150 voyez c'est des
vitraux quand même qui en cinq siècles
et qui nécessitent vraiment à soins très
attentif la france est le pays qui
possède le plus gros patrimoines de
vitraux dans le monde depuis près de 70
ans l'atelier familial participe à sa
conservation
les milandes de la consécration de
l'abbaye saint philibert de tournus en
saône et loire c'est avec vous ce matin
alors puisqu'on est dans les confidences
je vais vous donner un petit acronyme
vous avez quelques secondes pour
réfléchir mais pas trop non plus on est
vendredi matin c'est la fin de semaine
si je vous dis c ies mesdames messieurs
mais je crois qu'on va demander à fabien
écrire ça va être beaucoup plus simple
bonjour bienvenue fabien bonjour merci
de nous accueillir ça veut dire quoi ses
yeux un centre international d'études
romane et l'on se dit mais quel rapport
avec le lieu où nous sommes et via la
baie saint philibert est un des premiers
exemples en bourgogne de cet art de cet
art roman c'est à dire de l'art qui ce
n'est qu'ils n'aient autour de l'an mil
et qui va se développer jusqu'au 12ème
siècle dans les années aux 180 d'accord
et ce centre
il fait quoi le rapport à ces vieilles
structures qui est né dans les années 50
et qui a pour but de promouvoir l'art
roman de défendre le patrimoine médiéval
et d'organiser des expositions des
concerts des voyages des conférences
alors qu'est ce que vous répondez à ceux
qui disent oui d'accord tournus à romans
mais après tout vu
c'est un roman comme les autres ah non
c'est pas un as romans comme les autres
ils s'inventent des choses à saint
philibert de tournus c'est plutôt
ailleurs qu on a copié saint philbert
voilà oui bon ça m'intéressait là alors
dites-moi les y franco 3 par exemple le
déambulatoire derrière le derrière le
coeur comment faire concilier un
pèlerinage avec des reliques permettent
à une sorte de pré tourisme de masse au
xième siècle il fallait à la fois venir
dans la billy et puis en même temps pas
trop déranger les offices et que les
fidèles puissent voir les reliques
donc on invente une architecture oui
cette architecture vous la fait vivre au
travers de quelques animations parce que
c'est une année un petit peu
particulière on le vit depuis ce matin
on entend beaucoup parler
ce sont les mille ans de cet endroit là
officiellement on l'a compris on verra
avec l'hymne pajot d'ici quelques
minutes
c'est plus que milan 1 pour ses 18
siècle oui voilà c'est ça on n'était pas
là
non non non mais c'est important parce
que l'édifice qu'on a sous les yeux
à peu près mille ans et donc beaucoup
d'animations pour cette année 2010 9
beaucoup de conférences beaucoup de
spectacle le c ur lui est plutôt dans le
registre scientifique de d'organiser des
ateliers avec des archéologues et
historiens des incombe à un colloque à
la fin du mois de septembre
alors quand vous dites histoire
archéologie on pourrait presque faire un
alors plus qu'un livre il ya plusieurs
livres ici sur tournus j'en aller il y
en a des tonnes mais voilà voilà voilà
qu'est ce qui marque le plus cet endroit
où nous sommes ici tournus sur quel plan
historique bien sûr cela historique si
vous avez un des premiers exemples de
construction romane en bourgogne avec
quelque chose d'assez atypique puisque
généralement une église romane c'est
plutôt petit et sombre et là vous avez
une abbatiale qui est très autre très
lumineuse parce que précisément on a
inventé quelque chose ces fameuses arcs
doubleaux là on est un siècle après la
consécration mais c'est un édifice qui
s'est construit sur plusieurs décennies
est alors pour 2019 il y aura quelque
chose de plus précis plus particulier
que vous réservé aux téléspectateurs de
france 3 les un petit scoop peut-être
quelque chose de surprenant
surprenant non des l'habitude pour le
cerdd des concerts des conférences et il
veut rien nous dire il veut rien nous
dire bon allez faire un petit tour c'est
pas grave
et vous comprendrez que le cer organise
beaucoup de choses du côté de cette
abbatiale ici où nous nous trouvons à
tournus il ya un petit peu de vent mais
on va laisser le vent vous vous pousser
tranquillement vers la sortie mais
gentiment
merci merci fabien de nous avoir accordé
quelques minutes et puis on va les
retrouver
line pajot qui évidemment avec les
enfants notamment parce que vous êtes
aussi dans la vraie vie prof procès
histoire géographie en plus d'être
professeur de tourisme est d'abord
d'autres casquettes au sein de la mairie
notamment en matière de tourisme
je m'arrête avec vous parce que vous
emmenez souvent des élèves ici qu'est ce
que vous leur dites en premier comme
vous les a menés pour la première fois
quand je les amène ici et bien en fait
je les amène ici au coeur du système
donc au coeur du système c'est le seul
lieu où vous avez accès au ciel et c'est
à cet endroit là que vous avez une
synthèse de l'ensemble de l'abbaye qui
vous permet d'expliquer ce que fabien
clair a dit eh bien on a dû 11e jusqu'au
12ème siècle pour comprendre ce qu'était
l'abbatiale l'abbaye et tous les
bâtiments qui forme c'est avec cette
abbaye pardon oui parce que soyons
clairs une page où nous sommes sûrs
maintenant dans le cloître exact on est
ce matin dans le cloître c'est à dire
que derrière moi on à l'église derrière
vous et bien on à la salle capitulaire
on a autour
si on vous êtes allé tout à l'heure
voire une exposition une exposition de
vitraux et bien c'était dans le
réfectoire et une pièce dont on n'a pas
encore visité c'est le scellier mais il
faudra revenir à tournus pour aller voir
le cellier alors je vais vous dire on
n'a pas de trop de trop le temps ce
matin mais nul doute que 45 minutes ne
suffisent pas c'était évident et ça
c'était bien il ya les cloches qui
sonnent c'est pas pour rien ça veut dire
que on est dans les derniers instants de
cette émission j'ai envie de vous
demander ligne pages où le principal de
cette année 2010 neuf ici à tournus le
principal à ça ça va être très très
compliqué de trouver une synthèse
simplement moi ce que je peux vous
proposer c'est de venir tout l'été à
tournus parce que tout l'été on aura une
grande exposition qui s'appelle quoi de
neuf au moyen âge du 15 juin au 22
septembre et comme monsieur le maire et
comme monsieur le curé vous l'a dit on
va retrouver très régulièrement des
concerts qui vont ponctuer et bien tout
toute cette saison culturelle et dernier
point si je vous invite à revenir le 3
novembre pour la clôture est ici vous
aurez et bien vous aurez un spectacle
tout à l'heure on on parlait du galpon
et bien le gall peine investi l'abbaye
saint philibert donc je pense que ça va
être pas mal
tiens tiens tiens mais bon si j'ai une
petite surprise pour vous dans moins de
deux minutes avec quelque chose assez
sympathique on va parler d'un festival
que vous connaissez mais mais mais mais
mais line
juste avant j'ai insiste un peu qu'est
ce que vous diriez à ceux qui sont avec
nous ce vendredi matin et qui se disent
ah mais oui mais moi j'ai bien envie de
venir à tournus elle m'a presque
convaincu faisait presque convaincu à un
petit plus pour différents plus les
petits plus qui fait la différence
eh bien je vais vous proposait carrément
la journée complète à tournus vous venez
par le train vous venez par l'autoroute
vous venez par le bateau vous venez à
pied vous venez même en vélo à tournus
et puis avec l'exposition avec tous les
concerts avec le musée avec la ville
avec la gastronomie donc tournus est une
petite cité gastronomica si importante
je pense qu'il n'y a pas de petits plus
tournus c'est que des petits plus donc
il faut venir obligatoirement tout cas
merci pour votre accueil ici à tournus
encore
une fois on a été plutôt très rapide on
va pas se le cacher le mieux c'est
encore de se plonger dans les livres
d'histoire pour quoi faire
et s'il en savoir beaucoup plus sur
toute l'histoire de tournus de visites
et de découvrir de se dire que cette
année 2010 9 nous réserve plein de
surprises et on a compris parce que tout
le monde n'a pas non plus tout nous dire
vous lira pas trop grave bien de voir ça
j'ai bien compris on parler de ce genre
de festival vous commencez le séjour en
tournugeois le festival d'état le
détours en tournugeois à la fin août
début septembre et atteint très très
joli festival qui est itinérant sur le
tournugeois sur plein de petites
communes qui était l'année dernière à
tournus et quillan est pris l'année
prochaine
plus tôt cette année et bien ce va se
retrouver dans d'autres petites communes
c'est le festival du territoire et
vraiment je vous invite à venir
justement à faire un petit retour en
arrière sur ce festival populaire
comment je vais m or vous remercier
encore une fois de nous avoir accueillis
vous restez avec nous vous tous c'est la
magie de la télévision ont rajeuni de
quelques mois pour se plonger dans un
ancien festival qui laisse présager le
nouveau à mon avis et le renouveau de
tournus merci encore lisant de nous
avoir accueillis à tournus a très bien
la shabak souvenir nous plongeons dans
le festival détours en tournugeois
maintenant moi j'ai la dame est
est ce que vous pourriez regarder les
morceaux de cartons un magicien une
terrasse de café sur le marché c'est
aussi cela détours en tournugeois en
dehors des spectacles proprement dit ce
genre de petits cadeaux offerts à la
population témoigne du caractère
singulier de ce festival comme une
volonté de donner un autre visage à la
ville
je pense que c'est ça qui qui fait aussi
que ça donne beaucoup attendu ce
festival c'est que ça donne envie aux
gens de venir vivre ici faire des choses
monter des projets je crois que c'est
une ville qui est pas très grande et qui
a pourtant vraiment un gros potentiel
c'est une grande aventure je fais très
content d'y participer
parce qu'on l'a vue naître on a de se
développer en puis je peux apprécier
tout le dynamisme de ceux qui sont à la
tête de ça cela fait maintenant dix ans
que l'association galles bonne propose
ce festival qui se déplace dans le
tournugeois à chaque fois le site choisi
est rendue convivial et chaleureux par
une armada de bénévoles plus de 90 cette
année sans compter ceux des associations
partenaires
et puis ce festival a une autre
particularité il n'y a pas trente six
festivals en france qui sont programmés
par des artistes eux mêmes c'est à dire
que c'est une histoire de complicité des
artistes y croise d'autres artisans et
festival c'est une sensibilité c'est un
truc qui créèrent qui crée une qualité
spectacle que vous verrez nulle part
ailleurs parce qu'à la complicité parce
que les artistes veulent donner
lui aussi est une spécialité du festival
c'est le crieur public
ma mission est de chauffer le public et
j'invite à la jeune une flexion parce
que là je lui fais ctions permet
d'assouplir les membres postérieurs
d'une part mais surtout de pomper le
tellurisme si particulier du terroir
tournugeois finalement détours en
tournugeois et son crieur se ressemblent
un peu à la fois très rodé et hors des
sentiers battus
détours en tournugeois vous l'avez
entendu fin août début septembre pour
une nouvelle édition j'espère que vous
avez passé une bonne matinée avec nous
en tout cas nous avec toutes les équipes
on a bravé le vent mais nous avons eu un
temps magnifique
coucou fabienne et le sourire de fabien
de sa compagne et ouais non c'était beau
magique magnifique exceptionnel ça
continuera d'être magique pendant toutes
les vacances de pâques puisque ensemble
ce mieux ne s'arrête pas vous aurez le
meilleur à partir de 10h50
du lundi au vendredi avec aussi quelques
surprises
oui bien sûr plein de surprises tenez
pascal oublier le programme avec ce
gentil beau symbole pour voir revenir à
tournus ses katas que concerts
expositions conférences visites j'en
passe j'en oublie je vous conseille
d'aller faire un petit tour sur vos
écrans connectés pour essayer d'en
savoir un petit peu plus sur tout ce qui
se passe à tournus et puis pour
retrouver toutes vos émissions préférées
dont celle ci en replay merci encore une
fois à toutes les équipes de france 3
qui ont fait un travail formidable
à bientôt